you talked about the misconceptions of  the street fighters if you think you're  gonna have some magical powers because  you're angry or because your  adrenaline's going that's not true it's  going to cost you in a big way the  person that thinks if someone messes  with me I'm just gonna get wild that's  not gonna work especially getting  someone that's trained especially if you  come up against somebody like Tim  Kennedy who's genuinely trained a lot of  people train if you get no fight in San  Diego there's a decent chance you're  fighting against someone that knows how  to fight there's Jiu Jitsu academies  every street in San Diego yeah if you  just think you're going to be a tough  guy it's going to be a rough tour